foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I think that's what everybody here wants
is just answers
I honestly feel that the Palestine the
police department the fire department
all the First Responders they don't have
the answers to give us because I don't
think they know they're not getting the
straight answers either
foreign
we're trying to get information out to
our citizens everybody's concerned I'm
concerned we need our citizens to feel
safe in their own homes
because they're scared for their safety
[Music]
foreign
Southern is responsible for this problem
we fully expect them to live up to what
the CEO committed to me and that is that
they will pay for everything if they
don't we run attorney general here that
will file a lawsuit look they're
responsible for this they did it
[Music]
foreign
this is so much bigger than just it in
the water our environment our wildlife
animals our Farmers that have to till
their soil up
[Music]
we are recommending that people in the
community consider using bottled water
there we are awaiting results
of testing of the municipal water
sources that are going to be fairly
detailed and will allow us to have a
very complete look at the potential
compounds that could be involved